retour sur les évènements au liban à
tripoli seconde ville du pays où des
échauffourées ont éclaté entre forces de
l'ordre et manifestants dimanche soir et
après plusieurs jours de violents
affrontements et le rassemblement des
heures quotidien qui ont fait un mort et
plus de 400 blessés les manifestants
protestent contre les répercussions du
confinement strict imposé jusqu'au 8
février pour endiguer une propagation
exponentielle du cornât virus les
pouvoirs publics sont accusés de ne pas
épauler les plus défavorisés alors que
depuis plus d'un an maintenant le pays
est englué dans sa pire crise économique
depuis des décennies des décennies
écoutez à ce propos jamal al hawa kim il
est professeur d'histoire contemporaine
en relations internationales à
l'université libanaise
la crise va aboutir à plusieurs d'autres
manifestations il ya tout d'abord la
crise économique dans le pays mais il ya
aussi cette concurrence entre le premier
ministre désigné monsieur safari avec le
président de la république
en huit ans il y à des pressions
régionales de la part de l'arabie
saoudite d'une part et de la turquie qui
essaient de s'infiltrer au liban surtout
à travers tripoli
alors tous ces enjeux je crois qu'il ne
va pas aboutir à la stabilisation de la
situation jusqu'à ce qu'on forme le
nouveau gouvernement